the effects of a morning exercise
actually lasts 19 hours after your
workout you have to have some aim and
intention to have a phenomenal day
most of the time you're going through
the motions to just check the box and
feel like i got it done as opposed to
actually getting the feeling wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
i believe
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn seven habits
that will make you more successful
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one state your intentions with dr joe
dispenza what are the three things we
should say when we wake up in the
morning or think
well first i would say
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today
and i would not get up until i felt like
that person
the second thing i would say is can i
begin to keep my energy up the entire
day and if i do it properly then i will
be open to opportunities and
possibilities that weren't there before
the last thing i would say is could i
sustain
brain and heart coherence to the point
where that intelligence within me that's
giving me life begins to find a door to
open out so i can begin to see evidence
in my world habit number two
exercise with robin sharma move because
when you move in the morning and you
sweat you'll release bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor
which will optimize your cognition it
will make you think more effectively as
you go through your day
did you know bdnf actually helps you
promote neurogenesis which is actually
the creation of new brain cells bdnf
through sweaty exercise will also help
you repair brain cells that have been
damaged through stress powerful because
the quality of your brain sets up the
quality of your performance
sweaty exercise in that first 20 minute
pocket of move of the 20 20 20 formula
will also release dopamine which is the
inspirational neurotransmitter which
gives you fire in the belly as you go
through your day
universe
university of toronto did some research
and found that the effects of a morning
exercise actually lasts 19 hours after
your workout
cortisol the fear hormone is high in the
morning exercise will reduce it
exercise in the morning will release
serotonin which is the pleasure neuro
chemical which makes you feel happy
through the day now it's 5 20 you're
feeling fundamentally different habit
number three meditate with deepak chopra
i go to bed with the intention of pure
awareness
and settling into
infinite formless
identity
and i cultivate that awareness in sleep
i've been doing that for decades now
and so i have a
witnessing awareness experience even in
deep sleep or dreams
and there's a recognition that i'm not
the body-mind then when i wake up
you know before i get into the identity
of deepak chokra which takes a little
bit of time
i just have the same
awareness between
waking and sleeping and then between the
sleep state and the waking state is that
little gap of pure awareness
and i enjoy that
and then i start my meditation process
and uh it's all while i'm still in bed i
i'll obviously sit up to do that
and then i go have a wash or whatever i
have to do and then i do yoga i do yoga
seven days a week when i'm traveling i
still do my yoga
every day seven days a week in my room
i always get a yoga mat from the hotel
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four have a routine
with jim quick we make our bed we start
our day with excellence how you do
anything is how you do everything now
keep in mind one of the big questions we
got was
where do you get all the time right to
do all this and i'll show you i said
i'll go at the end how long each thing
takes but i'll give you an idea when i
make an event how is it going to take to
make your bed very very little but i do
this with excellence and then you take
excellence throughout your day i'm
remembering my dreams takes just two
minutes to go through
the next thing here making the bed only
takes one or two minutes
uh drinking water that doesn't take any
extra time if anything is just you're
always you're already doing it three
minutes exercise it adds things
absolutely because the big thing is
where do i get time because my goal is
for not this not to take time is to help
you to make time and focus and energy
and productivity and more um exercise
three minutes brushing my teeth should
take the same amount of time that's
interesting cold showers if anything
it's less time tea smoothies on occasion
sometimes i do intermittent fast and you
might have heard episodes of that i've
done
with past experts journaling
here's what i do i take three minutes to
journal and what on my journaling in the
morning i'm writing down three things i
want to achieve personally and three
things professionally now the biggest
way to save um
time on this is it's not just what
you're doing it's also what you're not
doing notice the thing i
said i i didn't say i did which is touch
my phone and i know this is
controversial i understand some of us
have to check our phones because our
life depends on it our career depends on
it again
take these guiding principles and apply
it for you habit number five design your
day with brendan burchard you can design
your days you can make your life about
what you want it to be about so what do
you want it to be about what should you
majority of your days be about for you
in terms of creating contributing and
connecting but they what should they
also be about for you your character
who's going to show up on your ideal day
what would you be like on your ideal day
would you be weak and fearful or would
you be courageous and strong would you
be judgmental and mean and upset full of
hatred and and jealousy and anger and
regret about life and other people or
would you be somebody who's open and
excited for other people and connected
with other people and positive and
enthusiastic what would you be like on
your ideal day have you ever written
that down here's who i would be on my
ideal day
here's how i treat my wife my partner my
spouse my lover the kids here's how i
treat strangers here's how i treat other
people and then the idea is don't wait
until the end of your life
to have that ideal day
don't wait until next year or next week
to have that type of day we can choose
to wake up every single day and live
that day in an idealistic way for
ourselves in a way in which we show up
as who we want to be in a way in which
we are doing things that enliven us and
engage us and get us excited in a way
that we're doing things and being with
people and creating experiences that
feel alive and fulfilling we can have
that type of life i call it the charged
life and everybody can have it it's a
matter of discipline in getting it and
here's one simple trick and tool to make
sure you get more of those ideal days
when you start your day you must own
your morning
you must own your morning look if you
thought about your ideal day i bet you
didn't say well i roll out of bed i grab
my iphone and i check my email right
that's not an ideal day you have to own
that morning to make sure that you're
proactive with that data say you know
what okay what is it i want to be about
this day what are the things i want to
achieve and create and experience this
day what kind of character do i want to
cultivate today what do i want to learn
today give today grow today you have to
have some aim and intention to have a
phenomenal day and it's not that you
can't go with the flow and the bumps and
the bruises and the struggles and
hardships of life
but when you're experiencing those you
can still experience them from a place
of presence and peace and enthusiasm
even the ultimate challenges in my life
and i've faced i've lost friends i've
lost my father to leukemia i've been
through my own multiple brain injuries
car accidents atv accidents broken
enough bones in my body it's kind of a
sad story really but every single
hardship i've ever faced including
leaving and starting my own business
even
moving to new cities every major
challenge obstacle in my life i always
chose
to meet that as my ideal self i always
say well how would my highest self
interact with this situation habit
number six keep your routine with mel
robbins i'm making the bed
even though we're checking out of the
hotel this morning
because every single morning i have the
same simple morning routine kit
i get up on the alarm rings i get moving
i get my exercise clothes on i move my
body i then journal do a brain dump i
make my bed
and even though we're checking out of
the hotel
um it's so important
to keep to your routine because the key
to changing your life
is change your daily habits
the way that you start to change the big
things is you change the small things
make tiny teeny teeny promises to
yourself and then keep them so i have a
promise to wake up and get up for myself
for years and years and years i would
get up to make the school bus i would
get up for school i would get up because
my mom was telling me to i would get up
because i had to get to work i would get
up to get my kids to school
today i get out of bed when the alarm
rings for myself
i make the bed
as a gift to myself
now normally when i'm home
the gift is i get to come back to a
nicely made bed
and i have a beautiful place to lay down
and dream
it's also a gift because i start my day
by completing something
but it's also a gift
even though i'm checking out of this
hotel this morning because
i am
building the foundation for all change
which is consistency
so here's how you put this into practice
think about what you want your morning
routine to be come up with just one
promise you're going to make yourself is
it going to be to get up in the alarm
rings is it going to be to make your bed
let's start with making your bed
tomorrow morning you're going to wake up
and you're going to make a promise that
you're going to make your bed for
yourself
do it every morning and you are building
the habit of consistency
and that habit of consistency is the
backbone to all change and habit number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is rewire with jay
shetty every weekday i wake up at 6 00
am i haven't set an alarm for a long
time but i know that my body will
naturally wake me up based on the
routine that i've created
i usually sleep for about eight hours a
night and i'm very grateful to have that
much time and i prioritize sleeping at
about 10 p.m every single day
when i'm up the first thing my mind
wants to do is say something like i feel
so tired i've got so much to do today
and i as soon as i wake up in that
moment
rewire and reprogram it to say i am
happy i am healthy and i am healing
that simple internal affirmation and
statement rewires how i feel about what
i have that day i'm grateful for the
opportunities in the work i have i'm
healing with the challenges i have and
my body is healthy because i'm able to
get out of bed i don't look at my phone
in the morning trust me i don't always
follow this i've broken that rule many
many times i'm not perfect i've failed
at it countless times but i keep trying
to rise back to this rule why because i
feel amazing the amount of clarity in my
mind the stillness that i experience
when my phone isn't the first thing that
i see
is
inconceivable and i highly recommend
that you try it out just for seven days
don't look at your phone first thing in
the morning and see how different you
feel for the rest of the day i promise
you you're going to feel more energetic
more productive and more creative than
you've ever been before now i've been
practicing something for a long time now
called mindful brushing i brush each
tooth for around four seconds before i
move the toothbrush this mindful process
allows me to start the day at my own
time in my own pace
so often before i used to rush brushing
my teeth not only would i be damaging my
gums and damaging my teeth by the way
dentists will tell you about that i
actually was starting my day off in a
panic with stress
slowing down the first activity of the
day
allows you to start and move at your own
pace in your own time now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch a video and just get motivated the
science says you have a 35 chance of
actually following through on your goals
that's not good enough no not for you
believe nation we got to do something
but when you write it down and you
create a specific plan of action for the
next week that number jumps to 91 chance
of you following through and when you
commit to somebody else like leaving a
comment on this video it jumps to 95 you
need to follow through on your goals so
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
you the most important part of a morning
routine is how you feel about yourself
it's the number one thing that people do
not pay attention to that matters the
most is how do you feel about yourself
when you're done your morning routine
nobody wakes up perfect nobody wakes up
full of energy yes ready to go wrong i
can't believe today is another day what
are they to be alive i'm so grateful i
like nobody nobody mel robbins evan
carmichael tony robbins nobody
the difference between where most people
are at and the people who have success
is that they demand
that they show up and they create that
through the routines and the habits
which is your morning routine it's the
easiest way to just get started so you
go from being tired and having stuff in
your eyes and lines on your face and
rolling out of bed to then feeling
inspired motivated ready to take on the
day
how do you do that well
you have to find the thing that actually
makes you feel powerful inspired
motivated confident and ready to go and
most people
just go through the motions and i'm
talking to the achievers now most of
america most of the world doesn't have a
morning routine at all they fall into
their day they wake up like an accident
and they start
falling to what other people want them
to do for the day like most people wake
up and just immediately go to their
phones see the crisis and they're
rushing off to go work on somebody
else's dream they wake up drive to a job
that they hate to work on building
somebody else's dream that's most people
you guys watching this you're probably
more on the achievers side you probably
have some kind of morning routine you're
probably doing more than your friends
and the people around you
the challenge with
achievers and the morning routine is
most of the time you're going through
the motions to just check the box and
feel like i got it done as opposed to
actually getting the feeling the most
important part of a morning routine is
the feeling
so i had
on my tour i had a woman
in albuquerque new mexico
talk about morning routines and she
asked me what mine was and i told her
what mine was but mine doesn't matter
what matters is what you're doing
and so i asked her what what do you do
in your morning routine well the first
thing i do every day is i pray okay
great so you pray and
let me let me ask you an honest question
i need you to be honest right now it's
important for me for you for everybody
here
how many times when you're doing the
prayer
when you've done the same prayer so many
times
when you when you're going through the
prayers how many times are you just
saying the words because you know the
words you've memorized them you see them
a million times
how many times you just saying the words
and how many times you actually feel
the deep connection how many times you
actually feel
the power flowing through you
and i forget what the number was it says
40 something like when she actually
feels the power like that's the problem
that's the problem with achievers
you are going through the motions
of your morning routine without without
ever having the feeling
so that you finish in one routine
whether it's 10 minutes an hour four
hours however long your morning routine
needs to be
if you don't feel confident alive bold
powerful at the end of your morning
routine then your morning routine isn't
working
i don't care that you check the box of
having done your prayers or watch that
video the number of people who watch a
video but then you're doing it while
you're making your bed or brushing your
teeth or eating breakfast or whatever
you're not ever really intentional about
watching the video that's great you can
check the box of saying you watch the
video but you didn't get the feeling so
it doesn't matter if you don't feel more
powerful confident ready to take on the
day at the end of the morning routine
then your morning routine is broken and
needs to be fixed and it's either adding
something new in
that actually makes you feel that way or
just doing the thing that you already
know works but with more intention
so that's what the woman need to do is
go back and fix some more routine just
with more intention
we often compare ourselves to other
people and their morning routines the
morning routine envy and say well
they're doing it so i should be doing it
like that i should be working out like
the rock four hours a day well that's
probably not what you want to be doing
the key is figuring out what makes you
happy what is the life that you want to
live understand that your routines
really are set up for you to have the
habits to follow through on success that
you're looking for right success is
habits success is what you do on a daily
basis and your morning routine sets you
up for that so how do we actually then
create a morning routine that works
right let me let me get practical move
from just inspiring to some tips that
you can actually go off and accomplish
step number one the most important thing
what makes you feel the belief in
yourself
of all the things that you do
that you've tried that you've done what
makes you feel the most belief in
yourself
maybe it's watching a video like this
it's why i design these videos to try to
be a part of your morning routine i'm
honored for anybody who is using these
videos
as that so thank you but whether it's
these videos whether it's reading the
book whether it's meditation prayer
working out getting in nature
petting your cats like what is the thing
that makes you feel
belief in yourself
that you're capable of more that today
can be a great day because you're not
don't have the expectations of you
waking up feeling great you won't you're
going to wake up like yes
but what is the thing that you do the
most that has led to you feeling that
love of belief
and you can string together a couple
like when i do this and this and this
and this great
this becomes a seed of your morning
routine
so make that list set number two
is there a sequence to them
what what's the one thing that when you
just start doing that thing it
kick-starts everything else
so that's why making the bed is is
something for a lot of people it's not
that making the bed actually makes you
feel motivated it's that you're the kind
of person who makes the bed and then
it's what happens next is that when you
make the bed you're more likely to then
do the next thing
you're picking something simple as the
first step not because of
it actually doing anything to make you
feel great is that it
makes you do the next step and the next
step and the next step so making your
bread brushing your teeth flossing your
teeth like whatever the thing is
what's the easiest part of the routine
because working out for example working
out's on your list that's hard
you might have lots of energy and
excitement now but tomorrow morning
you're going to wake up and not want to
work out even though you know logically
you know that working out will get you
feeling
expi not expired
inspired hopefully not expired inspired
motivated for the day you feel great
after a workout you don't want to do the
work in the morning
so don't make workout your first thing
something easier that you can fall into
so make in the bed
brushing your teeth or if there's
something else drinking a glass of water
like you're the kind of person who
drinks a glass of water in the morning
so then you follow through on the next
thing and the next and the next thing so
you start stacking them
right so step number one is you make a
list of the things that make you feel
the belief the courage the motivation
the fire and you you put that into
routine but step number two is now we're
going to order them and figure out what
is the easiest best place for me to get
started on these things
so that i can still follow through on
everything else that when i do that one
thing everything else cascades in order
and then step number three is just make
it realistic
make it realistic you can actually do it
one of the biggest problems that people
have with morning routines
is you
create this perfect morning routine that
takes you four hours to do
and it's unrealistic for you to actually
follow through on you'll do it for two
days and then realize wow this is
this is just not happening i'm not i'm
not doing it and what that translates
often is then therefore you suck
because you can't follow the routine
therefore you suck and then the whole
day gets thrown away and the next day
and the next day the next week and next
month nothing ends up happening
certainly being focused on something
that you're confident will have high
value to someone else
um and just being really rigorous in
making that assessment um because people
are
tend to
a natural human tendency is wishful
thinking
so a challenge for entrepreneurs is to
say well what's the difference between
really believing in your ideals and
sticking to sticking to them
versus
pursuing some unrealistic dream that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to to tell you can you
tell the difference between those two
things right now so you need to be sort
of very rigorous
in your self
self analysis
i think certainly extremely tenacious
and
and then just work like hell i mean you
just have to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour
weeks every week
guys
and then a lot of work that all those
things improve the odds of success okay
i mean if if other people are putting in
40 hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you know
that
in in one year you will achieve what
they achieve you will achieve
in
four months what it takes them a year to
achieve when you find yourself under
stress
and anxiety things go wrong you get
disappointments
things don't work out as you hoped you
must feel
a moment of anxiety a moment of stress
how do you deal with that what happens
um
i can
go out of the stress
i can at at any moment like there are
times where i feel the stress of the
circumstances
um and then i can
at will
go out of that stress
and just
see things
in a different way and it makes me feel
um almost like a ninja you know when the
in the ninja everything seems to come in
slow motion
you know and in the sense you could step
back and it's coming at me
at slow motion and i can deal with it in
in a way that makes me feel more
centered and in control but like tennis
players they say at the height of their
game
the ball seems to go much slower the
whole game slows down yeah and it's
really
that equanimity
that produces that kind of a reaction as
distinct from
when you have the anxiety
there's not the clarity there's it's all
coming too fast i always try to hire
people that are smarter than me and that
complement my skills skill sets like i'm
a ready fire aim guy and i always try to
partner with people that are very anal
and perfectionist to kind of balance me
out or have a skill set that i don't
have
but once i'm going i mean i would go to
events and like this and listen and
learn and go to conferences and when i
get the opportunity i'll ask questions
but i'm not i can't ever say ever what
i've said
i'm gonna call this guy and just see
what he thinks for this woman and just
ask that's just not my style i mean
because at some point i'm gonna have to
be responsible for whatever that
knowledge is
and and and also i have the benefit of
being in the technology business and
it's it's a benefit because there's
always something new coming and i've
always had the attitude that whatever it
is so if it's virtual reality if it's
the oculus rift it's new to everybody
except the people who invented it and so
i'm i'm at first base like everybody
else and then it's just a question of
effort of learning it as well as
everybody else so other than going to
the originator of the idea concept
product service whatever
i'm tied with everybody else and and
having the opportunity to learn it so
i'll just put in the time to learn it so
from a tech perspective and that that's
always served me well because once you
understand these different products you
understand how they fit together and it
also helps you make decisions and
understand what will work and what won't
work here's your new definition of
passion
passion is simply
energy
that's all that it is okay
passion
is what you feel
when you are energized and excited
about what you're doing okay i want you
to think about that for a minute i want
you to think about a moment in time
when you felt incredibly passionate
about something okay and why don't you
in the comments tell me where are you
watching from and tell me about a moment
in time when you felt incredibly
passionate about what you were doing
about where you were
about the people that you are with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to
really investigate
passion as energy
this is what you're going to discover
those moments when you're super
passionate like i'm sure my kids would
write down when they're doing community
theater with all their friends i would
write down whenever i'm doing any kind
of creative project with my team
i'm incredibly energized whenever i'm
doing group
exercise stuff climbing a mountain
doing a 5k race doing some sort of
walk-a-thon i'm incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm
doing some sort of creative project
incredibly energized by that whenever
i'm working with our video team
incredibly energized by that whenever i
am
coaching someone or giving advice i am
incredibly energized by that and so what
i want you to understand is that if you
look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt
passion
now i'm being very deliberate now i'm
talking this morning on coffee talk
because passion is a huge topic for so
many of you and you've been so focused
on trying to figure out what job is
going to make me
passionate what job is my passion what
is my purpose on the earth i'm going to
tell you what your purpose on earth is
right now your purpose on earth is to
figure out how to align your life so
that you feel more energized and excited
by it that's it
and it begins with you
following the energy and following your
natural enthusiasm you're not going to
think your way to passion you can't
think your way to finding something that
you feel in your heart it doesn't work
that way you got to feel your way into
it it's inside of you do you understand
there's no passion out there somewhere
the passion is in here and so what you
have to do first is you've got to stop
thinking that you're going to find it
somewhere and you've got to realize that
passion is about unlocking something
that's already in you
and so here's the thing
so for those of you that have been
watching coffee talk for a while or
you've read the five second rule book or
maybe used the five second journal or
maybe you took mindset reset with us
this january
you've probably heard me talk about the
fact that inside of you there is power
you have an inner compass
and that inner compass is always guiding
you and learning how to read that inner
compass is essential if you want to
unlock the passion that's already
naturally inside you
passion again isn't a person place or
thing that you're gonna find it is a
state of being that you unlock inside of
yourself and it is there and you can tap
into it right now
so there is an inner compass inside of
you that i call an energy gauge
it's an energy gauge that reads the
energy in you and around you and that
energy gauge goes from moments when you
feel depleted dead and empty to moments
where on the other side of the gauge you
feel energized alive expanded and so the
truth is
your natural state believe it or not
is to be on the energized expanded side
of the internal compass that's in you
and so you are never really lost i'm
telling you this i know you may feel
lost i know you may feel defeated i know
you may feel depleted i know you may
feel stuck these are all temporary
states and one of the fastest ways for
you to start to change how you feel
about where you are in your life is to
tune inward and to start to read the
energy because if you feel stuck your
natural energy is depleted if you feel
despair your natural energy is depleted
and the fastest way to start to shift
that is to shift the energy inside you
and to start to align your life towards
things that energize you if you practice
any new skill for 66 days in a row
through the power of
neuroplasticity which is the brain's
ability to adapt
then you are going to reach a point
called automaticity i want you to think
about that term automaticity in other
words after 66 days of practicing the 20
20 20 formula
and joining the 5 a.m club and running
the morning routine you're going to get
to a point where it's automatic you're
going to get to a point where it's
actually easier to get up at 5 00 a.m
than to stay in bed
i also want to offer you a brain tattoo
from the book to consider as you wire in
this learning protocol of billionaires
and highly creative people professional
athletes and industry titans and it's
this all change is hard at first and
it's messy in the middle and it's
beautiful at the end i'm going to repeat
that again for you because it's so
important all change is hard at first if
a new skill or a new routine or a new
habit was easy
then it wouldn't be valuable change
so anything that's valuable
is hard at first you know society says
live an easy life i suggest to you that
whether it's a great morning routine
whether it's building a great business
whether it's releasing your master work
to the world maybe it's a great
relationship maybe it's a great interior
life
it takes real effort it takes the long
game it takes focus it takes hard work
it takes bravery
but the rewards are so much more
glorious than living an easy life okay
so and also remember the things you once
found difficult
you now find easy little kids for
example find walking early on difficult
or learning a new nursery
rhyme or learning how to read or
learning how to build relationships at
first there's not a lot of facility and
fluency with those skills because every
skill is difficult at first until you
practice it and then train until you get
to a place where you master it and so
your morning routine is going to be
challenging at first but with daily
training
and practicing the 20 20 20 formula i
promise you you're going to get to a
point of mastery
and then the payoffs are extraordinary
your creativity will soar your
productivity will maximize you will
actually attract more prosperity into
your life because the marketplace
rewards true creativity and productivity
you're going to feel so much more
happier in your day you're going to find
that sense of peacefulness so it's
almost like you go through a life with a
greater level of grace and ease you know
the way you start your day determines
the way your day is going to unfold what
i want to talk to you about today is a
note which i call daily
so if you create a new note
in your notepad or something that you
check on a daily basis this is the most
important thing
name it daily
and then write the word do
colon
and then go down a few lines and write
the word don't
colon
the one thing i would ask you to do
walking out of this
is to every single day just for a week
wake up to this note
check it throughout the day
and then also before you fall asleep
check to make sure that you did and you
didn't do everything so what you put in
each one of these is you have a list of
everything that you want to do every
single day and you have a list of things
that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts is to
notice something that you never want to
do it again you never want to do again
and you just add that to it
very very simple i'm just going to share
some of mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but here we
are
number one on my do list is to stay
present
i think it's so easy to get trapped in
the past
it's so easy to think about the future
the most important thing is i stay
present and just reading this
brings me back to the present brings me
back to this moment
number two for me is be vulnerable
show people my mistakes
show people my fears
because they can relate
because they're going through similar
things
number three
drink only lemon water
and red wine
great red wine is a great modifier for
it
um this goes with one of my don't which
is don't drink hard liquor or beer on
weekdays
number three is uh six sets of 20 squats
and push-ups
throughout the day i just have to do
them every day
uh six sets of 30-second planks
run for three miles
meditate on this list
stand up straight
which whenever i say i always see
posture moving in the audience
say hello to everyone i just bought a
heavy bag so i'm training with a heavy
bag so i want to spend 10 minutes with a
heavy bag every day
i want to do a video journal
every single day and i want to get seven
hours of sleep
on my don't list and again this is one
of the hardest things and a lot of these
are personal so i'm not going to read
all of them
but my don't list is don't avoid eye
contact
don't be late
don't set expectations for someone and
not meet them
don't eat sugar
i'm on the paleo diet so don't eat wheat
lentils or dairy
and then of course don't drink hard
liquor or beer on the weekdays
um so this list well it sounds very very
simple has been fundamental in
establishing patterns for myself
and it's something that i do check every
single morning i check throughout the
day and i check right before i go to bed
and i make sure that i check everything
off
and go through it i've given it
to our companies
um i've given it to a number of students
that i've talked to as we've gone to
schools and recruiting and people have
come back to me and said that this is
something that works for me it's
something that's easy to do and
something easy to remember
one of the most fundamental things about
it that i've learned that i've taken
away from it is how it gives you focus
how it gives you something that allows
you to really ignore
everything else that's going on all the
other noise to allow you to focus on
what's most important so this do and
don't list for people and individuals in
the company has translated to a do and
don't list for our company
for square we have a do and don't list
we have these are the things that we're
going to do these are the core things
these are our bold bets and these are
the things we're saying no too for right
now
has been fundamental in allowing us to
move fast to continue to innovate and to
really push the boundaries and continue
and question
and and reset everything that we think
about the organization if you think
about
visualization is simulation
now here is the difference
that's good okay go ahead so
visualization is simulation so
when we close our eyes or even if our
eyes are open and we start to use our
einstein brain the imagination
we now have just activated one of the
biggest centers of our brain the
occipital lobe that's connected to the
motor cortex it's connected to the
motivational circuit the nucleus comes
that releases that dopamine that makes
you feel good that makes you want to
take action so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal if you
visualize yourself behaving in ways that
match the new belief if you even
visualize the words or you take the
words on a sheet of paper and you read
them run your right finger across it run
your left finger across it close your
eyes see it and feel it your brain is
creating a mental movie with the words
and as it creates a mental movie with
the words that's happening in your
subconscious mind
and when you give the subconscious these
instructions a couple things happen
because of the way the brain hierarchy
works number one it's survival but then
number two is safety
and then number three is energy
conservation now when you do something
20 30 40 50 times it takes about 66 days
to
365 days of repetition to override an
old habitual circuit not 10 days not 21
days 66 to 365. so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal feeling the
success that you want to feel
seeing the belief on the screen of your
mind you are actually creating a neural
network through the science of
neuroplasticity
and the networks that you reinforce
become the most dominant networks and
since your brain wants to conserve
energy
if you do this
on a consistent basis your brain says
okay
you're doing this so often let me just
make this automatic let me set aside the
old beliefs let me replace it with the
new beliefs and now you've deliberately
and consciously evolved yourself i mean
the balance of work and play is critical
and i think a lot of people don't get
that balance right you know i'm 63 years
old now so uh critical to
find time for yourself and get out there
and keep fit and and i find the best way
of keeping fit is by playing
i try to
encourage our chief executives worldwide
to make sure that there's as much
flexibility in in the workplace as
possible
we've set up something called the b team
which is examining the way companies
treat their staff and trying to make
suggestions to make the dignity of work
better than it's been in the past
[Music]
if you're too close to a situation you
know like in an office you get bogged
down with the menu tie
if you can step away from the situation
you can think about the bigger picture
and that's what i am able to do on that
the most extraordinary people come to
necca the elders was conceived here on
mecca with archbishop tutu with
president carter with kofi annan
the carbon wall room was conceived here
an organization that tries to work with
industry to try to extract carbon out of
the earth's atmosphere
you know sitting in muhammad looking up
at the stars at night things like virgin
galactic
so great place to think and a great
place to conceive ideas
well we had a fantastic day it was a
sunday so it wasn't all work so um a
great way of capping off the day watch
the super bowl with a cup of tea and uh
and a chair cheers
what is your strategy for dealing with
distractions
that's a great question
yes
something that
is that you've heard about
you've heard about this
but it's that thing like are you willing
to go to where you need to go and get
out your comfort zone
the number one thing that has been able
to help me with
distractions is two things
one of them is
prayer just taking two minutes
to quiet everything out and talk to god
and then the second thing which i was
like i can't do this
i can't even believe i said that
it's meditation
meditation
if
if that's one thing you'll take away
which
which
from today
is just go on youtube and say 10 minute
meditation
smooth music some type in anything 10
minute meditation i got to go see my
girl she mad at me you know what i'm
saying like
whatever it is
type it in
and and just just really kind of clear
your mind you guys are just getting
started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother i was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that i had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing i had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me i had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that i started doing was beating the sun
up every morning i'm gonna beat that sun
up every morning so that i had the
discipline and the control over my life
so i knew hey before that thing pops i'm
gonna pop i'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where i was was beat that
sun up no matter where i am i'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing i had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment
when i was younger between 15 and 25 i
was doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends i had the same
weekends or for the week
i was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people
making poor choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things
quit hanging out with people that did
not have ethics and discipline in their
life that weren't committed to the same
things that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing i had to do was
become someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick start your day
get going in your day to give you a
sense of respect for yourself
accomplishment for yourself look just
beating that sun up every morning gives
me the sense of accomplishment that i
did what i said said i was going to do
that i woke up when i said i would wake
up and i start building respect for
myself start believing in myself so that
i can go out into the world and maybe
maybe maybe today maybe today when i go
into this meeting that i'm dressed for
maybe they'll believe in me as much as i
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
well i have four children under the age
of eight he turned to eight last week so
time alone is even more sacred and it's
a time that i absolutely need to carve
out for myself so one of the things that
i did is i found out when my best
thinking time is and it's in the car
so i live only five or six minutes from
the spanx headquarters but i actually
many times leave my house an hour before
i need to be at work and go on a fake
commute
[Laughter]
so my friends have laughed and called it
my fake commute but i realized that's
when my mind wanders and
and that's when my ideas come to me and
so i have to carve that time out so i'm
driving around with all the other
commuters and i'm like the happy
commuter because i and i don't ever have
an agenda of where i'm going sometimes
i'm in inman park sometimes i end up in
downtown sometimes i'm in decatur i just
drive around
and there must be something for me about
the activity of driving and being able
to think and just listen to some
background music that accesses a certain
part of my brain and i read the other
day that einstein had all his best ideas
when he was shaving and so there must be
something about a rote activity that
you're doing that allows you to at least
at least for me it's driving so that's
one thing that i would say that i do so
find out and identify when your best
think time is and and make sure you're
you're making that happen in your life
and i'm not talking about when you're
just going through your checklist of
everything you have to do i'm talking
about when does your mind wander
and if you don't have enough time carved
out in your life for your mind to wander
you're not accessing the best part of
yourself
because there's there's a knowing inside
of you and it's when you're when you're
in that space not when you're watching
tv and not you know it's even more
difficult now with how much distractions
we have from ourselves at different
places
in life i promise you
you're gonna find
you don't know where to go
everybody goes through this the most
successful people in the world wake up
some mornings
with no clue
what to do today
okay so first thing i want you to know
is that it's normal it happens to
everybody it's not like you're a bad
person or you're lost or you're
depressed or
you you got some problem you need to
take medication for everybody everybody
regardless their stature in life where
they are regardless of their money their
relationship
their job they run the joint
promise you no matter how much they
present
like they look like they got the whole
package put together everybody
everybody
has those days and the sun is kicking
today has those days
where uh
they don't know what to do
i don't know what to do
you know uncertainty show up even if you
you feel terrible my friend dale
christensen told me when i was 25 years
old i was experiencing depression every
day he's like
no matter what man no matter what
no matter what dude show up even if your
eyes are bleeding show up i've been
doing that for 34 years now show up even
when i don't want to okay and then what
i try to do is i try to help one person
one person
and what happened over the period of 34
years i did that every day i'm not
depressed anymore at least not for long
periods of time i don't use any kind of
medication don't use any kind of drugs
don't smoke weed don't drink over
excessively drink i might have a drink
once in a while
and um
got a beautiful wife two beautiful kids
and for the most part my life is
freaking wonderful all i did was this i
don't over analyze
never do i label myself a loser a
quitter
um
i'm hard on myself i never i never label
myself ocd acd add
ocdd whatever a depressant uh alcohol
like a drug addict no no i don't this is
what i do i do things okay i show up
move in the direction i don't over
analyze move in the direction that that
that i think could be
more survival than staying in one place
and number three
help somebody i'm gonna share a little
trick with you and all viewers
you see these pencils here on my desk
i've got these all over the place
i got probably thousands of these
and i have this this is the lowest tech
thing you've ever seen sticky note
during the day here's one i just this
morning
i write down things i have to get done
i know it's slow tech there's all kinds
of software can do this for you i don't
care i like pulling a pencil
and simply writing down oh yeah i got to
get that thing done and just
making that note
i learned this from a very successful
person years and years ago my mother
and this note
just sits here all day and at night if i
haven't finished and usually there's
three or four i haven't done i look at
it and say
okay
tomorrow
i will get this done
before anything else before you know i i
go online before i read anything you
know i go watch television before i make
any phone calls or texts or anything
i'm going to get this thing done and i
stick it on the mirror on the right hand
side number one
record baseline for track 15. all right
so i found a piece of music that i
recorded back in 89 i'm working on a
documentary about
watch dials which i think you're going
to find interesting when i finally get
it finished but it needs the music so
the editors can work with the beat of
the music
and this thing i recorded in 89 does not
have any bass and i didn't play bass
back then now i do so i'm going to go
back in the studio and lay down the bass
track for track 15.
number two
reconcile foreign currency i have
investments
over in europe
and
each month i reconcile to the currency
to figure out how much of the
performance was gained or lost by the
change in the currency rates so i want
to do that this morning it's important
to get that done for last month because
you know
if you don't have that information you
can't make moves and
number three
tape questions four and five for tax
hive tax hive is a new business i've got
involved in as an investor and also as a
spokesperson
this is a company that helps small
business with their taxes and payrolls
very important in my portfolio companies
so i'm recording some messages and four
and five have to be done today so i'm
gonna go in the studio and record those
great take that's the one before i do
anything else today these three puppies
are gonna get done
and that is how you get super productive
and you don't let anything distract you
you don't take a phone call you don't do
emails you don't do anything you get the
things done that you made the priorities
the night before do it every day try it
it's fantastic look at this low tech
low tech you write it down a piece of
paper stick it on the mirror come on it
works there's a lot of emerging science
saying here's the reality and anyone who
wants to dismiss it is denying science
which is
planet earth is a tiny planet in a
galaxy of trillions of planets
um
my friend deepak chopra was on my stage
uh at one of my events a few months ago
he's a lovely man he just radiates
goodness
and um he took us on a tour de force
about cosmology and he's been a pioneer
for so many years and he confirmed the
science which is we are all part of an
energy source whatever you want to call
it god uh nature life and you're
absolutely right jay your intentions are
creative so we could come at it from a
cosmo cosmological point of view when
you say here's who i want to be you know
this morning in my journaling i'm going
to meet jay
i'm so delighted and blessed that he's
invited me on his show because he
influences so many people how may i
serve
that intention
hopefully is creative so we're very
powerful
i'll come at it another way which is
epigenetics
epigenetics as you know
stands for the emerging field of science
which is you are not your genome the old
school said your dna what you get from
mom and dad that's your destiny we're
now realizing that epigenetics means
our environment our daily rituals like
getting up at 5am our thoughts
what we eat our peer group etc
literally affects the up regulation or
down regulation of our genome
what does that mean it means
if you believe in yourself if you do the
work in the journaling if you get up at
5 00 am and do that victory hour and go
through the 20 20 20 formula you
literally are recalibrating who you will
become out in the world so you're
absolutely right then you start
channeling your intentions
and you start stepping into your power
like we are awesomely powerful beings
most of us have blocked our intimacy
with our true power
[Music]
if you want to learn the 10 best habits
to have in your life check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there
when you're feeling gratitude and your
heart is open you're broadcasting energy
into the field now frequency the
frequency you lay the intent of the
thought of your health or your wealth